here are this week's top movies from  director Clint Eastwood comes Sully  the incredible true story of an airline  captains heroic emergency landing this  is the captain  brace for impact am I ever going to  survive on this island in the family  adventure the wildlife Robinson Crusoe  teams up with a band of animals to save  their tropical paradise I'm gonna be a  father a surrogate mom turns stalker in  the steamy thriller when the bough  breaks should kill you baby today  what do you mind Joe you need to be  nicer to me this is my baby let's check  out this week's fantasy patient so  what's your weekend ticket going to be  let us know by commenting see you next  time on weekend ticket